if you were confused at all about what
exactly happens at the end of season two
then stick around to the end of this
video sponsored by [ __ ] TV welcome back
to things you missed the year is 1930
and not more than 11 seconds into season
2 we've already got a guy going on a
rampage against his family why is this
guy so angry and what does this all have
to do with the rest of the season taking
place on a rural farmhouse what is the
significance of this place harbor why
does look see come after this family and
most importantly what does any of this
have to do with season 1 these are all
questions I'll be answering on today's
episode but let's start at the beginning
of season 2 episode 1
our location is New York City and this
man Robert Capshaw has just finished
taking out his family and I'm not
talking about taking them out for dinner
he hears an angry mob outside and
finishes the job by slitting his own
throat the blood lands on the newspaper
article of Robert and his twin brother
James Capshaw the spatter only covers
robert's half of the photo telling us
that the brother is probably still alive
the same trick using the blood to show
who's no longer alive is used again
later in the season on the daughters
drawing of the family but why did Robert
go crazy on his family the answer is in
the setting as we saw earlier the scene
takes place in March of 1930 it looks
like the Capshaw twins opened their bank
in the heat of the great economic
depression for all of you international
viewers not a good time to open a bank
in the USA now the other brother James
Capshaw took the dignified approach and
got the heck out of there
he moved his family to this remote
farmhouse
[Music]
this day-to-night transition is really
cool not only does it reminded me of
hereditary but instead of using that
annoying click noise that the daughter
and hereditary makes we hear one tick
from the stopwatch that looks he carries
around using the stopwatch to show the
passage of time and look see very cool I
couldn't help but think those next scene
was another homage to a 20-18 horror
movie was anyone else reminded of a
quiet place so anyway James Capshaw goes
to check things out at the barn when he
finds a foreclosure notice from his own
Bank interesting note here this stuff at
the farmhouse doesn't take place right
after the scene in New York City the
date of the foreclosure notice is Monday
August 1st the next time August first
falls on a Monday after this opening
scene assuming that the series uses
real-world calendars is August 1932 so
two years go by between this and this
but it seems that even in these two
years james hasn't let go of the fact
that his business failed because as
we've seen previously in season 1
[Music]
the fact that James's note is written on
a dollar bill is further proof that it's
the bank started by him and his brother
that he was unable to release when he
started his new life in the country we
never actually got to see what body part
Luke's he would have taken from him
though because our buddy dead meat beats
him to the kill marking probably the
first time that James has added to his
own kill count which I think might be
cheating in a way I don't know I don't
make the rules but if I went on to a
horror movie set and placed a bunch of
things you missed all around would that
really be fair to add to the mystery in
a sense one of the thieves gets stabbed
by a pitchfork off-camera and we never
see if Luke C is responsible or not I
personally don't think that he would
have gotten that deep of a stab just
from falling on the floor
but if Luke's he is responsible then
this is the only victim who doesn't
receive a note also no body part is
taken from this victim I think it's a
new side of Luke see like if you try to
interfere with his dealings he'll just
straight-up kill you Nightmare on Elm
Street anyone before we move on from
this first episode I think it's
important to note that each character's
fatal flaw is set up here in episode 1
the second episode is about the other
thief we can see his remorse start to
kick in when the blood starts to shed
something that he probably did not sign
up for when he agreed to become a thief
he finds that his pocket watch has been
replaced by the look-see watch at the
end of episode 1 and the second episode
finds him regretting his actions having
nightmares about his dead thief buddy
who by the way looks way too happy to
have a pitchfork going through his torso
and eventually it looks he it rips him
in half which is representative of him
getting half of the share of whatever it
is that they were stealing was the third
guy out of the picture the wife Mary
Capshaw can be seen clutching her pearls
in the first episode which she does
again in her episode episode 3 you can
just see her general discomfort being at
the farmhouse and her episodes title ii
love tells me that her love for her
family falls second compared to material
things like her fancy new york apartment
her necklace and high heels she's
ultimately given the choice between her
family and her material possessions when
her deceased son appears before her with
her necklace that was broken in the
previous scene now fully intact she goes
for the necklace first and as you can
probably imagine looksie doesn't like
that and takes her heart because her
heart was in the wrong
plays she was in that marriage out of
the love for money and material things
not love for her family then we've got
the older brother David Capshaw played
by my buddy Johnny Berchtold he can be
seen carrying around this bear which
formerly belonged to his late little
brother I know a lot of people were
confused by his fatal scene because he
eventually does rip the Bears head off
in an attempt to show look see that he's
not holding on to his deceased sibling
however he still does pay the price I
would compare this to the woman letting
go of the ring in the very first episode
in season 1 and the father from season 1
who throws away his dead daughter's
birthday cake despite the fact that
these characters are able to let go of
their physical possessions they're still
targeted because what look see is
looking for as an emotional release and
David Capshaw never really has that
moment so he's left with his head turned
around 180 degrees like the father from
season 1 he's punished because he's
still looking backwards not forwards so
that covers all of the characters who
had their lives taken by look see but
they're also two characters who survived
this time around dead meats character
Raymond and the little girl Lea Capshaw
Lea seems to be the one who's working
with Luke see this season leaving the
note in the back of her picture crossing
off the family members as she takes them
out and being the only one to see look
see early on and not really look scared
I think that Lea already had an
encounter with look see and she was able
to release whatever it was that she was
holding in just like jenny was
eventually able to do in season 1 before
becoming a look-sees assistant
Lea also bears a strong resemblance to
the dead daughter in season 1 episode 3
more on that later
then we've got Raymond who gets his
buddy's blood poured on him carry anyone
[Music]
and look-see curiously just lets him go
in order to explore the reason why I'm
gonna refer to James's recent kill
accounting video on dead meat Rowlands
would a deeper look into Raymond's sole
murder and all leaves look see a little
less smiley than usual and he drops
Raymond to the ground guess this guy
didn't have anything to release so he
takes all this pieces and walks off into
the woods
so my analysis of what's happening here
is that Raymond is a sociopath he
doesn't hold on to anything so he has
nothing to release I also think he's
most likely gonna be working with
look-see in the future as one of the
assistants just like Jenny and Lea I
think the shot where Raymond is first
introduced also kind of suggests that
there's some similarity between him and
look-see
also at the very end of James's
killcount video there's another little
clue and of course huge thanks to kripp
TV for partnering with me for this go
cow again make sure you subscribe to
them because there will be more of me on
that channel in the future just sayin
he's probably not making that up but now
we can get into the real interesting
things you missed and the clues about
the ending after a hand comes out of the
teddy bear evil dead to anyone and
look-see ultimately kills David the
little sister can finally scratch off
the last of her family members and she
returns to look-see with the stopwatch
then this happiness
[Music]
notice how the new hands are burning
blue gloves instead of red also notice
if you look at this shadow the new look
see has something attached to its head
let's look back to the original drawing
done by Leah you can see the look see
hiding in the dark looming above the
Capshaw family I can see the dad the mom
the brother the sister and the deceased
younger brother with his teddy bear but
what's this other character hiding in
the dark behind look see I think that is
the second look see if the original is
made up of the body parts of those who
could not release and wears a suit maybe
this other version essentially the baby
looks he wears a bow on its head I think
the new look seat will be made up of the
body parts acquired throughout season 2
you can even see that the head is
divided vertically much like the thief
who got torn in half but what happens
with the second look see and how does
this affect the original look see I
think now is a good time to address the
timeline of events obviously both
seasons take place in the past but where
do they fall chronologically we know the
exact date of season 2 but we don't know
exactly 1 season 1 takes place the
episode titles suggest that season 2
takes place after like how the first
season has an episode called the wedding
hand and the second season has an
episode called in the second hands or
how the mistress mind in the first
season has the counterpart the second
love in season 2
however I've come to the conclusion that
season 2 is a prequel in rewatching
season 1 I noticed this photo with a
pickup truck in the background it looks
like a more modern vehicle and I'm a no
car expert but I looked up what a pickup
truck looks like in the 30s and since
then we came to the conclusion that
season 1 is more or less modern-day
that's when it all came together for me
about how the two seasons are related
[Music]
the end of season 2 shows the creation
of the new look-see then pulls out and
shows us again the name of the area that
they're in harbour in episode 4 of
season 1 13 high school kids are
poisoned and died if you look at the
banners in the background you'll see the
name of the school Harbor High this is
the same area that looks he ends up
prowling throughout season 1 which takes
place 80 to 90 years later to spread out
farmhouses in the middle of nowhere
eventually become a community a high
school is built that looks he remains in
the area all the while to make sure its
citizens always release their sorrows
remember how I said that Lea looks a lot
like the guys daughter in season 1
episode 3 they aren't the same person or
the same actress but I would theorize
that the girl and her father are
descendants of Lea Capshaw so the big
question becomes what happens to the
second look see with the blue gloves
well you better subscribe to [ __ ] TV to
find out in the next season of look see
of course you'll be treated to more
scary short films every Tuesday Thursday
and Friday in addition to their three
videos a week trip TV releases limited
edition merch like this awesome looks
t-shirt I'm wearing right now if you
want a chance to get your own just sign
up for the cripton newsletter and you'll
be the first to hear about new designs
I'll leave a link in the description if
you're interested next video I'll be
discussing sunny family cult and the
origin of look see tap or click the
video on the left to go back and
re-watch all of looksie season 2 so you
can let me know what I missed in the
comments or watch my things you missed
on the first season of Luke seen by
going to the video on the right until
then I will see you in the next one
assuming we both survived
[Music]